[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bienvenue dans ces idées qui gouvernent
le monde le numérique de l'émancipation
à l'alien nation en ce temps qui
accumule les crises crises sanitaires à
peine terminée conflit dramatique en
Europe avec la sale guerre russe en
Ukraine économie déprimée et inflation
montante persistance des inégalités
socioculturelles populisme et
nationalisme en quête de nouveaux
territoires et la liste de cette
conflictualisation du monde n'est pas
exhaustive et ben dans ce cadre-là le
numérique reste néanmoins au cœur de
l'actualité pas seulement parce que
l'homme le plus riche du monde Elon Musk
c'est offert le tentaculaire réseau
Twitter avant de le dépecer de sa
substance humaine comme sans train de le
faire c'est congénères américains du
numérique mais aussi parce que le
numérique coche toutes les cases d'une
révolution à l'enseigne clivé de
grandeur et décadence liberté
surveillance progrès technologique et
tribalisme des pratiques bref la
révolution numérique est la est à la
double enseigne de l'émancipation et de
l'Allier nation avec ce que cela
comporte de transformation profonde de
nos sociétés et d'anomie sociale c'est
ce que nous allons chercher à comprendre
avec mes invités que je vous présente
Daniel Cohen vous êtes économiste
directeur de l'École d'économie de Paris
Charlène Biondi vous êtes docteur en
sciences économique Joannas Haddad vous
êtes avocat et co-président de la
Fondation Concorde Margot Klein vous
êtes présidente du fond
héritage
[Musique]
la révolution numérique nous vient des
États-Unis avant de gagner le reste du
monde
Daniel Cohen comment vous expliquez
cette première contradiction économique
il y en a bien d'autres qu'on va
chercher à comprendre c'est fondateurs
avaient l'ambition initiale de répande
partout le progrès social la démocratie
est finalement ils se sont muets en
redoutable capitaliste et leurs
enseignes sont devenus des machines si
je peux utiliser ce terme à hyper cash
alors ce qui est vrai des des fondateurs
on pense au fondateur par exemple de de
Google qui au départ était très inquiet
que leur logiciel de recherche puisse
être perturbé par des considérations
marchandes et qui sont venus en l'espace
de quelques années d'ailleurs sous
l'influence d'un économiste qui
s'appelle alvarian en effet des machines
à cash ou tout a été fait à l'adverse de
ce qui était annoncé pour utiliser les
données des informations qu'ils avaient
leur disposition pour pour générer du
cash mais au-delà du destin de ces
personnages je pense que c'est toute
l'histoire du numérique qui est cette
image dans les années 70 quand ça quand
ça commence le numérique Internet et
d'abord un instrument de communication
des chercheurs aux États-Unis entre les
universités et les pionniers je crois
sont habités par une idée
libertaire une idée venue de la
contre-culture des années 60 que ils
allaient mettre à la disposition de la
Société des instruments qui allaient
permettre de se débarrasser de la
verticalité d'abolir la verticalité du
monde qui était lui-même l'objet de la
critique de cette contre-culture des
années 60 donc il pensait en effet
qu'ils allaient créer un type de société
tel qu'elle a pu être rêvée sur les
campus américains ou dans le monde
entier à l'image de ce qu'on appelle en
France mai 68 à savoir une société d'un
type nouveau en horizontalité plutôt
qu'en verticalité mais ça ne s'est pas
passé comme ça pour plusieurs raisons et
pour faire court en partie je crois du
point de vue encore en généralité de de
ce récit parce que après la Révolution
libertaire des années 60 on a connu une
contre-révolution conservatrice des
années 80 qui a continué par d'autres
moyens presque opposés à l'intention
initiale des des jeunes des années 60
qui a continué cette
désinstitutionnalisation du monde non
pas pour créer un monde d'horizontalité
mais pour créer un monde de mise en
compétition des différents segments de
la société donc
l'ambition d'une société en
horizontalité c'est transformé dans les
années 80 en l'ambition d'une société
régie par la compétition et c'est ce
mélange bizarre d'une inspiration
anti-système libertaire d'un côté et
d'une mise en compétition générale qui
s'organise avec la révolution
conservatrice des années 80 dont je
crois en partie
l'esprit des réseaux sociaux aujourd'hui
se nourrit est-ce que le numérique fait
advenir c'est ce composé bizarre d'une
culture
anti-système et en même temps une
culture profondément de compétition de
rivière qu'ils étaient sincèrement
généreux et ils sont devenus sincèrement
mercantiles on peut le résumer comme ça
vous acceptez ça Margaux
ce qui vous a motivé au départ c'est
d'être sincèrement généreuse ou
sincèrement mercantile c'est-à-dire
gagner de l'argent moi j'ai commencé
dans le numérique en 2015 donc ça fait
quelques années maintenant
je pense que
opposé la générosité et être mercantile
déjà il y a quelque chose qui qui ne va
pas pour moi après le numérique là vous
parlez d'entreprise américaine pour la
plupart
qui ont des objectifs on les connaît
aujourd'hui on les connaissait pas à
l'époque si on se recentre sur l'Europe
moi je trouve que c'est important de se
focaliser sur des entreprises
européennes françaises notamment qui ne
sont pas toujours dans cet objectif-là
donc moi quand j'ai commencé le
numérique ce n'était pas mercantile
c'était simplement le cas de tous les
jeunes en tout cas un jeune sur deux
aujourd'hui qui veut se lancer dans le
numérique pour être indépendant pour
avoir une alternative aux salariat pour
avoir une alternative au niveau des
chances tout simplement donc liberté ça
on comprend mais est-ce que c'est aussi
volonté de gagner beaucoup d'argent pas
je pense que gagner beaucoup d'argent
aujourd'hui c'est possible le numérique
est une opportunité parmi tant d'autres
ça a créé plus d'un million d'emplois en
15 ans aujourd'hui c'est seulement 17%
des entreprises qui sont dans le digital
c'est bien mais c'est pas non plus
extraordinaire comme chiffre c'est 100
milliards de vente annuelles en France
donc
c'est bien mais c'est pas
révolutionnaire en termes de d'argent je
pense que l'argent aujourd'hui il est
clairement ailleurs il est aussi dans le
numérique et c'est très bien mais il est
aussi ailleurs alors on va essayer de
préciser les choses il y a une autre
contradiction que celle qui a été
énoncée là maintenant
si on prend
des grands dirigeants comme Elon Musk
Jeff Bezos Mark Zuckerberg et leurs
émules en France en Europe et ailleurs
ils nous ont sorinés à leur début que
c'était une révolution dont le but était
de libérer
les personnes de leur contrainte or ce
qu'on voit aujourd'hui c'est qu'en
termes de Libération les gens sont ADDES
en addiction ils sont accros à des
écrans des réseaux sociaux des croyances
irrationnelles comment vous expliquer
cette contradiction Charlène Biondi
effectivement les dirigeants des de la
tech aujourd'hui d'ailleurs ça se voit
souvent dans leur slogan d'entreprise
Google de Google dans le pays
le slogan palantir make the worldber
c'est des slogans très émancipateurs
très
qui se fonde sur cette rhétorique techno
utopiste qui est née comme la rappeler
Daniel Cohen dans les années 60-70
autour des premiers ordinateurs et de se
mouvement contre culturel
mais cette rhétorique
utopiste émancipatrice liée à la
technologie dans l'histoire des
techniques c'est pour ne pas dire une
anomalie c'est une exception totale
c'est à dire que depuis Marx on a
toujours considéré que la technique
c'était a priori où l'appareil technique
était a priori l'instrument des
dominants et que le reste du monde ne
pouvait être que soumis à l'impératif
technologique la technologie numérique
parce que c'est la première qui a été
qui a offert la possibilité d'être à ce
point manipulable pour la première fois
elle n'est pas tout de suite d'ailleurs
les premiers ordinateurs dans les années
60 les manifestants à Berkeley en 64
détestait la technologie numérique DTC
les ordinateurs ils manifestaient dans
la rue et ils comparer l'état dominant à
un ordinateur c'est avec le
libéralisation entre guillemets du code
informatique des premiers jeux vidéo etc
on a commencé à comprendre que
l'informatique pouvait potentiellement
être un outil pour l'individu et plus
pour des systèmes ni que ce soit l'état
technocratique ou que ce soit le
capitalisme dominateur et cette
rhétorique a été hyper puissante et
aujourd'hui elle infuse tout le
marketing et toute l'idéologie
sous-jacente de ceux qui traînent dans
latex qu'on croit aujourd'hui le
dernière technologie numérique la
blockchain quand on écoute les les
idéologues enfin comment on appelle ça
les évangélistes
sur cette contradiction de l'idée de
liberté qui devient un enchaînement vous
pensez qu'ils ont rien vu au début que
les gens seraient accro à ça alors déjà
c'est jamais possible d'anticiper tous
les effets secondaires d'une technologie
donc on peut on peut très bien
s'imaginer que les concepteurs au départ
on ne pouvait pas pouvaient pas on
pouvait pas anticiper que les effets que
les effets que la mise en pratique d'une
technique allait avoir sur le sur le
monde social en revanche
les algorithmes sont clairement
aujourd'hui construisent des réseaux
sociaux face à l'économique c'est ce
qu'on appelle l'économie de l'attention
c'est c'est la logique économique
derrière Google et derrière les réseaux
sociaux
dépend de la de l'utilisation de
fréquente de des utilisateurs donc
mettez-moi de faire préciser à Jonas sa
date qui est avocat qu'est-ce que vous
pensez vous de cette mise en cause de la
liberté parce que finalement les gens
qui sont sur les écrans sont pas libres
en fait si on fait de l'histoire du
droit c'est des conceptions très
différentes de la liberté et dans le
fond ce que ce que disent les autres
intervenants est assez censé dans le
sens où c'est une conception très
américaine de la liberté c'est-à-dire
que la conception américaine de la
liberté c'est considérée que la liberté
d'expression totale la liberté
capitalistique totale la liberté de
faire ce qu'on veut est une liberté
alors que notre conception européenne
est française et c'est dans les
premières années droit qu'on apprend ça
c'est de dire que la loi protège mais
finalement va venir nous libérer va
venir réguler et donc on le voit bien
d'ailleurs dans les conceptions
différentes avec le rgpd européen l'idée
c'est de dire que la liberté numérique
par la régulation et l'idée profonde
américaine c'est que la liberté se crée
par toute la dérégulation alors à un
moment c'est une dérégulation
woodstocken 68 armes après c'est une
dérégulation thatcheriennes et
régalienne et puis maintenant c'est une
dérégulation effectivement de personnes
et à la différence de ce que vous y êtes
à l'heure moi je ne pense pas qu'il ne
soit au départ pas totalement conscient
de ce qu'ils font je pense qu'ils sont
que en tout cas les manières de la tech
sont pleinement conscients de ce qu'ils
font et qu'ils veulent comment dire
imbriquer leur conception de la liberté
sur ce qu'il pense je vous donne un seul
exemple le méta vert
dans la tête de Zuckerberg le metavère
est une liberté parce qu'en fait vous
allez sortir dans l'univers d'une
société qui est difficile dans lequel il
y a des contraintes etc et vous allez
libérer dans cette sorte d'Eden mais qui
est zuckerbère pour décider que le meta
vert qui virtualise la relation sociale
est une liberté et bien Zuckerberg et
l'héritage effectivement de cette double
révolution de ce cocktail qui était
décrit jusque auparavant qui consiste à
dire que ils sont aujourd'hui des
façonneurs de notre société et donc
c'est à la fois sa puissance financière
mais aussi le fait de dire que il est
beaucoup plus
légitime dans le nombre de personnes il
avait dit une fois Zuckerberg a un chef
d'État vous savez moi j'ai plus
d'adhérents sur ma plateforme que vous
de citoyens dans votre pays mais pas
sans si vous voulez aux questions
économiques Daniel Cohen d'un point de
vue économique vous connaissez très bien
ces fameux chiffres le 1% de la
population la plus riche qui concentre
un pourcentage très élevé de la richesse
et le 1% mais d'après vos études à
l'École de Paris vous allez plus loin
parce que vous dites le 1% c'est vrai
mais si on regarde non pas le 1% en bas
mais le 20% c'est à dire une masse
considérable de français par exemple on
s'aperçoit que leur pouvoir d'achat a
certes augmenté mais leur part dans la
richesse nationale a diminué est-ce que
vous pensez que
la part de ces 20% les plus pauvres
est-ce que vous diriez que c'est une
conséquence de l'intelligence
artificielle ou en tout cas quel lien
vous faites entre l'intelligence
artificielle et le creusement des
inégalités et de cette perte de richesse
des classes moyennes parce que 20% on
est dans les classes moyennes
donc on est alors d'abord effectivement
sur les chiffres et pour rester aux
États-Unis puisqu'en effet ce mécanisme
né aux États-Unis et l'explosion des
inégalités aux États-Unis est à couper
le souffle n'a aucun précédent dans
l'histoire humaine pour donner des
chiffres très très simples à comprendre
la part du 50% le plus pauvre la moitié
de la société américaine la moitié
inférieure de la société américaine est
passé entre 1980 et aujourd'hui
de 20% du revenu total et 50% gagnaient
20% du revenu total et aujourd'hui ils
sont descendus à 10% du revenu total
donc leur part relative a été réduite de
moitié la moitié de la population
américaine ne gagne aujourd'hui que 10%
du revenu total au cours de la même
période le 1% le plus riche aux
États-Unis gagnaient au début 10% du
revenu total aujourd'hui il en gagne 20
et en France en France c'est beaucoup
plus modérée 1% est passé de 8 à 12 en
gros mais pour prendre des Etats-Unis
puisque c'est là que se joue
l'interprétation que l'on peut donner de
cette relation entre les inégalités les
années 80 de Thatcher et ce phénomène
numérique et je crois qu'il y a un lien
étroit mais pas de causalité directe
mais de mise en résonance ça veut dire
que aujourd'hui aux États-Unis le 1% le
plus riche gagne en masse
deux fois plus deux fois plus que le 50%
le plus pauvre donc si vous voulez
vendre un produit si vous vous adressez
aux 1% le plus riche vous avez face à
vous un pouvoir d'achat qui est du
double en masse à dépenser de celui que
vous auriez trouvé chez des 50 % donc le
1 et le 50 ont permuté leur place
c'était très bien mais quelle
interférence avec le numéro
donc d'interprétation que j'en donne ce
qui s'est passé au cours des années 80
c'est un mécanisme dans lequel comme je
disais sur l'interprétation qui a été
faite en quelque sorte de Regan et cette
chair de ce moment historique qu'on
vivait ça a été un moment de
déconstruction des entreprises telles
qu'elles existaient dans les années 50
et 60 à savoir des mondes sociaux tout
en verticalité qui était donc à la fois
à la fois très inégalitaire du point de
vue des rapports humains n'obéissaient à
quelqu'un qui obéissait à quelqu'un qui
obéissait à quelqu'un mais
paradoxalement très intégratrice en
matière économique au cours des années
d'après-guerre ce qu'on appelle en
France l'étranglorieuses tous les
revenus augmentent mais en parallèle
l'un à l'autre pour une notion presque
stupide qui est que tous les univers
sociaux à l'époque appartiennent à des
entreprises qui ont les mêmes grilles de
salaire donc quand l'un augmente quand
un patron dans les années 60 seugmente
de 10% de 10% la femme de ménage ou
l'homme de ménage est augmentée de 10%
aussi donc il y a une marche quasiment
parallèle de tous les revenus ce qui se
passe dans les années 80 c'est que enfin
de ménage le service d'entretien les
cantines pour commencer sont sortis de
l'entreprise le rapport de subordination
qui existait auparavant au sein
d'entreprise et transformer en un
rapport de donneurs d'ordre à
sous-traitants on sort de l'entreprise
tout ce qui n'est pas considéré comme
essentiel au fonctionnement de
l'entreprise et tout ça est généralisé
donc en fait les entreprises sont
coupées en mince couche
font vivre chacun entre même et la
percolation de la richesse qui était
inscrite dans le fonctionnement de nos
sociétés sociétés industrielles d'hier
la démocratie mécaniquement empêchés
donc les entreprises ne sont plus que
des agrégats de personnes de personnels
parfaitement homogènes je vous ai
rappelé les statistiques aberrantes qui
se passent aux États-Unis en matière
d'inégalité la grande surprise des
chercheurs c'est de découvrir que au
sein des entreprises et non pas entre
les entreprises les inégalités ont
quasiment pas changé pourquoi parce que
on est entre soi donc au sein d'une
entreprise où il n'y a plus de disparité
sociale en réalité les niveaux de
revenus restent le même avant quand un
ingénieur avait une idée géniale dans
une entreprise automobile tout le monde
en profitait là maintenant ça reste
confiné à la sphère étroite des membres
de cette de cette entreprise ou vient le
numérique et bien ce monde désarticulé a
besoin social considérable trouver la
manière de fonctionner or les murs
traditionnels ou je donne un ordre à X
qui a y et AZ redescend jusqu'en bas et
ce monde il a été inventé à la faveur de
toute cette déréglementation ça commence
par des choses extrêmement simples le
fax donne un moyen de donner des
instructions très précises à des gens
qui ne sont pas dans votre entreprise
évidemment l'essor d'Internet qui
commence avec arpanète comme on
l'appelait dans les années 70 dans les
années
90 donne évidemment le coût d'envoi un
monde où les coudes communication sont
complètement réduites donc le lien entre
les deux c'est tout simplement ça c'est
Madame sets disait la société je ne sais
pas ce que ça veut dire je connais des
individus c'est exactement ça qui se
passe à partir des années 80 le
numérique est au service d'une société
qui considère qu'il n'y a que des
individus qui vont tous se brancher sur
la toile pour pouvoir communiquer entre
eux et
qui est exactement ce qui est inscrit
dans la révolution conservatrice des
années 80 c'est que ces individus sont
mis en réalité dans cette plateforme en
compétition les uns avec les autres vous
parliez de l'économie de la tension
simplement pour se faire entendre sur
internet il faut un langage qui vous
oblige à vous faire reconnaître en gros
en parlant plus haut plus vite que les
autres en montrant l'innommable enfin
bref on est dans une concurrence sauvage
pour pouvoir se faire entendre
évidemment tout ça ne prête pas à la
conversation philosophique sans
habituelle du terme où il y a un respect
de la personne en face on écoute ces
arguments on lui répond c'est juste
impossible sur le net parce que la
course à l'intention le rend impossible
vous êtes également un politique puisque
je crois que vous êtes élu du conseil
régional de Normandie quand vous écoutez
ce que dit
Daniel Cohen le numérique tue la
relation sociale bon je j'exagère en
disant ça mais avec une espèce de
reproduction en quelque sorte et
d'accroissement des inégalités qu'est-ce
que ça vous fait mais en fait je pense
que si je reprends le titre de
l'émission il y a une forme d'aliénation
mais qui est une aliénation qui est une
élévation collective mais l'émancipation
individuelle elle est présente parce que
ils n'en reste pas moins que le rêve
initial qui était celui des créateurs
d'Internet et de d'emmania de la tech il
peut aujourd'hui quand même être touché
du bout du doigt quand on voit par
exemple ce qui se passe avec des
familles iraniennes ce qui voit ce qui
se passe en Occident et qui ont envie
par ce biais là parce qu'elles ont la
connaissance internet quand on voit ce
qui se passe dans un certain nombre de
pays dans lequel il y a eu des
révolutions qui sont mises contre des
tyrannies par le bilan internet
l'émancipation individuelle de
l'individu elle existe après que dans
les structures sociales ça a été
conséquences créatrice d'inégalités
c'est c'est du rapport économique
deuxièmement mais vous vous acceptez
cette idée là que ça crée en tout cas ça
favorise la disparité économique et ça
l'entretient en quelque sorte ça
l'entretient mais ça ne veut pas dire
que que qu'elle n'ouvre pas d'autres
potentiels quand on parlait tout à
l'heure des jeunes et des nouvelles
générations qui aujourd'hui considèrent
par exemple que l'instrument monétaire
n'est plus un instrument qui est
légitime ils vont aller dans les crypto
monnaie mais pour commencer ils vont
utiliser une critique mais n'existait
pas d'outils numériques pour le faire il
en aurait pas la possibilité comment
enfin si je prends je veux pas atteindre
très rapidement le point Godwin mais on
peut se poser la question de savoir
est-ce qu'un certain nombre de génocides
qui ont été commis l'aurait été s'il y
avait internet alors là ça ouvre une
autre question ça ouvre la question
d'une troisième zone dont on n'a pas
parlé parce que c'est comme ça aussi
l'enjeu c'est la question asiatique
parce qu'aujourd'hui on parle beaucoup
des Etats-Unis on parle beaucoup de
l'Europe mais aujourd'hui la puissance
de la tech asiatique et équivalente oui
mais là nous on fait pas de ségrégation
on met on met en question le numérique
quel que soit ses frontières pour vous
dire que dans la conception asiatique la
réponse à votre question là les
négatives parce qu'elle vient
complètement aligner l'individu d'accord
alors Margot Klein on va passer à ce
qu'il fâche c'est à dire le financier et
les monnaies numériques puisque quelque
part c'est votre domaine avec le fond
hér alors on parle de Bitcoin si on
parle de blockchain de crypto monnaie
leur efficacité vient quelque part de
leur anonymat mais il y a des risques
d'évasion fiscale il y a de la
spéculation dernièrement l'actualité
c'est l'effondrement de FTX
sincèrement et crypto-monnaie c'est un
progrès
alors déjà pour revenir sur tout ce qui
est la grande question des crypto
monnaie l'anonymat le blanchiment
d'argent je pense que ça existait bien
avant les crypto monnaie on n'a pas
attendu les corruption ça date depuis
que le monde existe on a attendu les
crypto monnaie pour mettre ça en place
ensuite quand on connaît bien les crypto
monnaie on peut voir que c'est
impossible d'être anonyme sur la
blockchain donc blanchir de l'argent sur
la blockchain il faut être soit stupide
soit naïf c'est beaucoup plus facile de
le faire sans blockchain donc déjà c'est
déjà une question qui est à mettre de
côté ensuite pour FTX c'est une très
bonne un très bon sujet et FTX c'est
intéressant le cas de FTX parce que
c'était une plateforme centralisée donc
FTX on peut le comparer à une fight
bancaire comme on l'a vu en 2008
pourquoi parce que FTX était centralisé
et posséder les fonds de ses clients
donc ça n'a rien de blockchain ce
n'était pas décentralisé c'était
centralisé ils ont pris ses fonds et les
ont mal managés ils sont sous le coup
d'une enquête on verra ce que ça donne
dans le cas vous parlez de l'héritage.io
ce n'est pas quelque chose qui aurait pu
se produire on ne possède pas les fonds
des clients donc c'est ce qu'on appelle
non custodial une banque mais vous
placez les fonds des clients on place
les fonds des clients mais les clients
mais vous leur mettez vous leur
promettez la lune ou pas on leur promet
pas la lune ni mars comme Elon Musk ni
des fusées qui atterrissent toute seule
on leur promet simplement de pouvoir
investir à partir de 1000 euros sans
passer par une banque en possédant leur
fonds et en ne laissant pas leurs fonds
dans une plateforme centralisée c'est
simplement ce qu'on offre il y a aussi
des rendements qui vont avec mais la
progrès technologique et qu'on travaille
sans banque avec la tokenisation
peut-être on en parlera tout à l'heure
puisque vous
alors
un pays assez avancé en matière de
blockchain de plateforme et de
tokenisation et c'est très simplement la
fractionnalisation d'un actif donc comme
une société par exemple on va diviser
une société en petite partie et on va la
rendre accessible à des montants plus
bas et plus attractif pour tout le monde
on peut faire ça avec l'immobilier on
peut faire ça avec à peu près tous les
actifs qui existent alors Charlène
burdim vous êtes convaincu vous êtes
convaincus parce qu'il vient d'être dit
là sur il y a pas de risque financière
avec les crypto monnaie etc j'ai pas dit
qu'il y avait pas de risque financé avec
les clients mais je pense que sur tous
les marchés financiers il y a des
risques
d'où la rémunération il y a des risques
ne disons pas qu'il y a des
FTX est un cas par d'après ce que
alors va acheter que c'est pas tout à
fait un cas à part parce que les les
faillites et les scandales se sont un
peu accumulés dans le milieu de la
crypto ces derniers temps enfin il y a
eu l'effondrement de stable donc une
monnaie virtuelle censée être stable qui
en fait la pas du tout mais
effectivement FTX c'est pas exactement
un représentant idéal de la technologie
blockchain parce que comme comme vous
l'avez dit c'était une plateforme
centralisée pourtant elle faisait bien
du trading en crypto monnaie mais c'est
très important de distinguer les deux
c'est une c'est une confusion qu'on fait
systématiquement parce que la blockchain
est née avec l'invention du Bitcoin qui
est une crypte qui est la première
crypto-monnaie mais la blockchain dans
une technologie peut servir à plein de
choses qui ne sont pas forcément les
crypto-monnaies y compris dans le
domaine finesse dans le domaine
financier ou en fait elle peut être
utilisée par des institutions
financières parfaitement régulier les
banques qu'on connaît aujourd'hui voir
les banques centrales pour pour
faciliter des échanges donc tout
simplement des paiements de façon
beaucoup plus fluide que les
technologies déjà numériques qui sont
utilisées aujourd'hui du style switch et
compagnie Daniel Cohen en médecine et à
ce qu'on appelle la prévention en
principe la prévention en pêche la
maladie de d'arriver de ce qu'on peut
avoir une prévention financière pour
qu'il n'y ait pas de nouveau Madoc sur
de
nouveaux se dirigeant d'eftx est-ce
qu'on peut détecter ça un peu avant pour
que les gens soient pas floués
quelquefois de leur maigre économies
toute l'histoire des crises financières
c'est toujours une course-poursuite
entre la régulation qui s'applique en
général à un état du monde témoins et
des innovations qui visent je parle
depuis le début du XIXe siècle qui vise
toujours toutes à contourner ses
réglementations voilà c'est toujours
comme ça que que ça se passe et je vois
ça comme une nouvelle une nouvelle étape
donc là
la question de la dès qu'on fait appel à
l'épargne publique il faut un cadre
réglementaire il faut un cadre
réglementaire qui permet à des
régulateurs des agences de notation mais
surtout à dérèglementations publiques
savoir exactement les risques ça risque
pour un avertir les clients mais aussi
pour voir s'il y a un risque systémique
associé au fonctionnement de ce de cette
collecte de l'épargne de l'épargne
public donc c'est c'est vraiment aussi
simple que ça l'exemple des FTX
parfaitement représentatif vous avez
raison de comparer à la crise des
subprimes d'une certaine manière et
c'est sans doute différent de la
question des blockchain mais on a un
exemple typique un appel à l'épargne
public qui n'a pas fait l'objet d'une
réglementation et le bonhomme Apache
c'était pas un ponzy si j'ai bien
compris mais c'était juste qu'il a pris
des risques insensés dans l'espoir de se
refaire ça c'est toujours comme ça il y
a toujours un moment vous avez un
placement et puis ce que les économistes
appellent le Gumball for resurrection
c'est ça c'est le moment où vous êtes en
train de descendre sous la ligne de
flottaison il faut prendre toujours plus
de risques pour essayer de vous en
sortir avec cette espèce d'asymétrie
d'incitation qui est
la Société Générale donc autre chose
mais juste pour dire quand vous êtes
vous devez rendre 100 et vous êtes
descendu à 90 en fait vous êtes en
faillite donc en fait que passer 90 à 80
ou 70 ça n'a plus aucune espèce
d'importance parce que vous êtes en
faillite par contre passer de 90 à 180
ça c'est bien vous remboursez faites un
profit donc plus vous rentrez en perte
plus si vous n'êtes pas régulé vous êtes
incité à prendre des risques pour
essayer de vous refaire c'est ce Gumball
donc c'est pour ça qu'il faut des
régulateurs ce câble de dire vous êtes
en perdre on arrête vous recapitalisez
où vous sortez mais vous ne continuez
pas au sein même d'ailleurs des banques
ou des institutions financières on on
veut chaque soir connaître la situation
pour éviter au trader solitaire alors il
y a quelque chose de de Kerviel dans
cette histoire mais on veut absolument
éviter que le trader solitaire se
retrouve en situation de vouloir à
chaque parfois prendre le risque de
faire sauter la baraque pour se refaire
lui donc tout ça ça s'appelle la
réglementation la régulation et elle est
indispensable tout ce qui vise à la
contourner pour moi c'est un risque
alors quand c'est la petite zoo à la
limite bon les gens avaient qu'à savoir
il y a toujours un moment où on prend un
risque systémique on l'avait vu avec les
hedge fonds LTCM fi provoquer une crise
financière qui n'a finalement pas créé
mais parce que dès que ça rentre en
résonance et qu'on se rend compte en
réalité que tous les risques sont
corrélés entre eux alors on risque la
grande crise financière comme celle
qu'on a eu dans les années 2008
maintenant juste un mot parce que c'est
important par rapport à la crypto
monnaie au blockchain etc les banques
centrales réfléchissent à la possibilité
de le faire elle-même parce que c'est
vrai que c'est c'est pratique ces trucs
là mais je veux de la réglementation
aussi mais les banques centrales peuvent
émettre une monnaie certifiée banque
centrale alors là pour le coup il y aura
pas de problème de réglementation parce
qu'elle connaîtront peut-être trop tous
les détails de ce qui est détenu par les
uns et les autres donc là faudra des
régulateurs pour éviter à ce pouvoir de
s'exercer le problème si elles font ça
mais pour moi ça n'en est pas un il faut
réfléchir à la manière de gérer c'est
qu'elle détruise toutes les banques
commerciales parce que là pour le coup
elles auront très vite le monopole
exclusive de la gestion des crypto
monnaie il faudra un protocole qui
permet de rendre ses fonds à des bons
commerciales ou à des établissements
financiers pour qu'il bénéficient des
pas on est un peu à ce point
d'hésitation où on n'ose pas aller trop
loin dans le domaine public de peur de
déstabiliser le système privé mais comme
la nature Aurore du vide il faudra bien
trancher un moment donné une précision
le fond héritage vous êtes en Suisse
est-ce que vous êtes en Suisse parce que
les réglementations sont moins
rigoureuses on va jamais choisi la
Suisse pour des raisons plus
personnelles alors est-ce que les
réglementations sont-elles dans
certaines pays moins rigoureuses que
dans d'autres alors moi je connais
l'Europe
qui n'est pas un pays mais quand même
une région économique importante et la
Suisse la Suisse aujourd'hui c'est le
premier pays au monde actuellement à
avoir autant légiféré sur le domaine
blockchain crypto monnaie et
tokenisation donc c'est les numéros
actuellement ils ont fait des lois très
justes et très sophistiqué donc la
Suisse et aujourd'hui le pays le plus
régulé donc c'est très lourd la
réglementation en Suisse pour ces
sociétés là mais c'est possible donc
nous moi je suis d'accord avec Daniel
Cohen on joue le jeu de la régulation et
de la réglementation c'est obligatoire
pour moi aujourd'hui c'est obligatoire
si on veut éviter des dérives comme on a
vu avec FTX ou autre en début d'année
donc la Suisse elle est très rigoureuse
là-dessus l'Europe aussi maintenant avec
la loi Mika qui arrive il y a aussi
Christine Lagarde qui a annoncé les
présidente de la Banque centrale
européenne et qui a annoncé les CBDC qui
a un projet déjà lancé qui est déjà là
elle a annoncé les trois grands facteurs
qui vont arriver donc c'est là si on
joue pas pour moi le rôle de la
régulation ça vaut pas le coup
[Musique]
Jonas
de renseignements du numérique collecte
de nombreuses données on s'aperçoit que
ces données peuvent être là pour nous
contrôler qui a une espèce de
surveillance à grande échelle est-ce que
vous vous avez le sentiment que sur ce
plan là il y a un danger pour la
démocratie il y a un danger pour la
gouvernance politique
est-ce que ce qu'on appelle pour
simplifier ce néolibéralisme
algorithmique il peut mettre en cause
finalement les questions de justice de
liberté de gouvernance voilà parce que
quand j'entends ce genre d'affirmation
ça me fait toujours penser à ce que
m'avait dit un officier de police
judiciaire lorsqu'il y avait eu un
premier contrôle une fois on était en
garde à vue il me dit tu sais
les gens mettent sur Facebook
100 fois plus d'informations que ce qui
nous aurait donné si on les avait
interrogés en tant que policier c'est à
dire que par nature les réseaux sociaux
qui sont une exposition de ce qu'on est
foncons donne beaucoup plus
d'informations déjà de façon volontaire
donc le fantasme initial qui consiste à
dire que l'objectif de ces sociétés
serait le contrôle ben en fait il est
alimenté par chacun d'entre nous qui est
l'instrument de son propre contrôle dans
ce cas là donc ça c'est un premier point
un deuxième point on en revient aux
différentes conceptions des États qui
vont faire des régulations là-dessus
évidemment il y a des étapes pour qui
c'est une source absolue de contrôle on
peut parler de la du Crédit Social à la
chinoise qui va en fait il voulait par
tous les éléments que vous allez
communiquer
permettent de contrôler votre conformité
avec les normes sociales qui sont
édictées d'ailleurs en centralisant
l'ensemble des actes de votre vie vous
savez aujourd'hui à des plateformes en
Chine dans lequel vous faites à la fois
votre paiement
votre messagerie mais également un
certain nombre de sujets en France en
Europe c'est encore pas le cas c'est à
dire que vous payez quoique Apple paye
ça arrive mais globalement vous vous
mettez des informations et des photos de
famille sur Facebook vous payez avec une
carte bancaire et vous faites un chat
avec du SMS ou du WhatsApp donc c'est
pas encore centralisé sur l'intégralité
mais en revanche ce qui est certain
c'est que la conception même
des Mania de la tech qui ont envoyé des
milliards en recherche pour permettre
cette développement du numérique c'est
dire la phrase d'ailleurs des fondateurs
de Google qui dans une conférence de
presse qui est devenue célèbre qui dit
très clairement
la vie privée
est quelque chose qui est obsolète
et quand on est de dire entre la vie
privée c'est obsolète et permettre à un
état pour ne pas le citer la Russie de
faire de l'activisme pour modifier le
résultat d'une élection
on est là devant un système de
perversion démocratique ah mais c'est un
système de perversion démocratique si
vous voulez mais qui est quand même au
fond toujours à l'initiative des états
c'est toujours la conception étatique
qui va infuser la conception américaine
qui consiste à dire que le plus
important c'est la transparence plutôt
que la vie privée nous et c'est en ça
qu'en tant qu'Européen on a notre rôle
c'est le président de la République dit
souvent en européen mais là je trouve
que c'est un vrai sens en européen de
dire qu'est-ce qu'on a à raconter dans
la culture chinoise le collectif prime
toujours sur l'individuel donc le plus
important c'est que l'harmonie sociale
soit présente quitte à aller regarder ce
qui se passe dans la vie privée des gens
ou pas il a réussi tout à l'heure
là aussi le concept global de l'État en
Russie on le connaît c'est celui de la
Citadelle à siéger c'est à dire que les
Russes ont un concept global consistant
à se voir comme toujours assiger donc
s'ils veulent éviter la citadelle ils
peuvent le faire alors maintenant on
doit en tirer des conséquences et notre
conséquence c'est notamment pour nos
entreprises très souvent on dit il faut
créer un Google européen où il faut
créer un métaver Européen et à chaque
fois on y arrive pas pourquoi on
n'arrive pas à prendre ses vagues parce
que au lieu de vouloir comme on le fait
très souvent en Europe généré par l'état
des entreprises qui moi avoir la
capacité de se projeter par rapport à ça
on bride nos entreprises et dans toutes
les eaux les autres pays on ouvre et je
termine avec cette anecdote là par
rapport à votre question en Europe on a
mis beaucoup de barrières sur les
questions de vie privée et de données
personnelles et c'est très bien pour les
individus
mais pas pour les aides mais il m'arrive
très souvent de voir des entreprises qui
viennent me voir en disant nous c'est
très important le rgpd pour nous parce
que ça nous permet de protéger nos
données mais je dois avouer que on
utilise des logiciels américains
asiatiques israélien avec des
conceptions de la vie privée dans lequel
il y en a pas du tout et donc si vous
voulez notre volonté de protection fait
aussi qu'au final on se met dans les
mains d'autres États qui ont eux une
conception différente de ce que c'est
que la vie privée oui alors à votre avis
Charlène Biondi est-ce qu'il y a quelque
chose à faire au niveau institutionnel
voire des Nations Unies pour empêcher
tous ces dérapages
qui sont possibles par le numérique qui
porte atteinte à la gouvernance à la
politique etc
alors je pense que beaucoup beaucoup de
choses ont déjà été faites quand on a la
première fois qu'on a c'est pas
exactement la première fois mais si la
première fois qu'on a eu des preuves que
les États effectivement avaient accès à
nos données c'était grâce au lanceur
d'alerte Edward Snowden en 2013 a
commencé à parler de surveillance de
masse
et puis tout le monde tout le monde a
été horrifié d'apprendre que les élèves
les services américains la NSA et une
partie des services européens
pouvaient collecter absolument tout ce
qu'on toutes les toutes les données
personnelles les mais toutes les
métadonnées que qu'on avait entre temps
c'est ce qu'on appelait le enfin le
Snowden paradoxe c'est à dire que les
États n'ont pas vraiment arrêté ces
pratiques de collecte de données parce
que d'un point de vue stratégique c'est
impensable de se dire bah très bien donc
toutes ces données existent elles sont
énormes et on est en plein contexte de
lutte dans tes terroristes on va les
laisser aux entreprises au privé puis
nous et tard on va rien collecter on va
réussir à faire notre enseignement
différemment c'était impossible donc les
états ça a été le cas en France et aussi
aux États-Unis on fait des nouvelles
lois pour encadrer les pratiques de
collecte et d'analyse de données de
leurs services de renseignement
évidemment c'est toujours un sujet
aujourd'hui le rgpd est bien plus récent
et je pense que la démocratie libérale
est parfaitement armée pour
contrer les externalités de son économie
c'est d'ailleurs le jeu B le KGB et elle
mafia russe ne sont pas
en état de respecter de en état de
respecter ces choses là
effectivement
ça mais ça c'est un ça c'est un mood
dans ce cas on passe on passe à un autre
un autre aspect du conflit sur la scène
internationale effectivement la
technologie elle fait elle fait partie
des nouvelles armes c'est un nouvel
instrument de conflit c'est un nouvel
enjeu des conflits et là dans ce cas
dans ce cadre là le numérique devient
nouveau terrain ça c'est c'est tout à
fait pertinent mais c'est c'est
et encore une fois les états s'adaptent
la France la France le fait le fait au
Mali on s'est fait on a eu plein de fake
news et des ingérences dans la campagne
française les services français ont été
très rapide à faire pareil au Mali
sur cette question de la surveillance
dans les fonds que vous gérez à travers
le fond héritage etc vous êtes sûr que
les informations ne s'évaporent pas
pareil que alors nous déjà on a une
obligation et on a choisi de la
respecter d'être transparent avec les
autorités financières donc ça veut dire
que tout ce qu'on fait d'un point de vue
financier et transparent on a émis des
documentations tout est transparent
White Paper on appelle ça
prospectus une documentation technique
financière c'est pas mal de documents
transparents au niveau des données
clients là on passe par un organisme
régulé au niveau de la Confédération
suisse ou au niveau d'un État européen
donc là on ne détient pas les
informations ces informations sont chez
un organisme agréé qui va s'assurer de
la sécurité nous on est tous en Suisse
donc il y a pas on vous a dit de des
États-Unis où je ne sais pas quoi
[Musique]
alors cette intelligence artificielle
fait penser aussi à ce qui se passe en
médecine avec le transhumanisme et le
lien entre les deux peut exister
c'est-à-dire est-ce que vous avez
conscience de cette chose là que le
numérique
et le transhumanisme
ont un peu la même volonté de créer un
homme nouveau pour parler avec
grandiloquence comme Nietzsche il y a
deux manières de voir le monde
dystopique vers lequel on peut aller le
premier c'est que le numérique et
l'intelligence artificielle
avec toutes les données dont on vient de
parler à être en pratique capable
d'avoir une information précise
rigoureuse sur les 8 milliards d'humains
qui forment cette planète pas il y a pas
d'obstacles à ce que on sache tout de
vous
n'importe qui d'ailleurs d'une certaine
manière mais que une machine quelque
part sache tout de vous ce que vous êtes
ce que vous faites où vous êtes et où
vous voulez aller on a tous fait
l'expérience de faire un voyage de deux
heures et d'attendre deux heures dans un
aéroport de voir passer la douane dans
un monde à venir on n'aura pas besoin de
passer la douane puis alors exactement
qui vous êtes rentré déjà ma fille
habillée habite à Londres dans les
supermarchés c'est un peu à Paris le
dimanche mais vous entrez et vous avez
déposé votre carte de crédit dans un
club de fidélité et puis vous prenez
vous partez il y a pas de caisse on sait
exactement tiens voilà la voici elle
prend on repère donc on est dans un
monde où une certaine manière
l'intelligence artificielle va être
capable de gérer optimalement les
humains dans leur corps quand ils se
déplace dans les aéroports ou dans les
supermarchés dans leur carrière aussi
déjà commencé mais quand on est
aujourd'hui candidat dans une université
à travers parcoursup il n'y a pas
d'humain derrière à regarder votre CV
c'est des algorithmes qui ont fonctionné
tel critère vont vous recruter dans les
recrutements maintenant déjà mais ça va
certainement s'amplifier vous pourrez
avoir une position ici pour faire ceci
ou cela et rien interdit de faire cette
proposition à un million de personnes
parce que l'intelligence artificielle va
sélectionner les 10 candidats que vous
verrez à la fin évidemment en face à
face mais sur une base peut-être
planétaire et on se projette encore plus
loin il y aura même pas besoin de faire
acte de candidature c'est déjà en
pratique un peu en train de fonctionner
comme ça sur Linkedin on viendra vous
chercher et même d'ailleurs faire acte
de candidature serait une mauvaise chose
ça voudrait dire que vous n'êtes pas
dans une situation qui est bonne donc on
viendra vous voir vous avez fait tiens
j'ai vu que vous avez passé des vacances
à Singapour que vous avez Bacha pourquoi
vous donc on peut imaginer et là on
n'est pas dans le transhumanisme on est
juste dans l'intelligence artificielle
qui pourrait pour reprendre je vois que
vous avez le livre La Fabrique du crétin
digital qui en même temps qu'elle
crétinise l'individu à travers ses
pratiques addictives sur les réseaux
sociaux prend en charge l'intelligence
collective du système sont que l'humain
aurait été soit en contrôle de ce qui
lui arrive parce que on vous fait une
offre quoi d'où ça vient et c'est comme
ça alors la manière
de rivaliser avec cette espèce de
dualité entre l'intelligence systémique
du côté de l'intelligence artificielle
et la bêtise du côté des humains c'est
des non non on lutter contre ça l'humain
peut se mettre des branchements dans les
électrodes pour être aussi puissant que
la machine c'est se transhumanisme dont
vous parlez voilà alors écoutez il nous
reste tellement peu de temps que cette
ce qui vient d'être dit est extrêmement
intéressant mais on a très peu de temps
peut-être brièvement que vous puissiez
chacun dire est-ce que vous avez le
sentiment que ce monde virtuel ce monde
numérique porte atteinte à vos
sentiments à votre intuition
à ce qui à votre intimité Margot Klein
il faut être très vigilant à ce que
l'humain reste au centre de tout donc il
faut être très vigilant à ce qu'on va
demander à l'intelligence artificielle
et de la façon dont on va l'utiliser ça
c'est un point de vue
vous une frontière une barrière entre
votre activité et votre intimité il faut
il faut vraiment faire la différence à
sa date sur cette frontière elle existe
aussi pour vous je pense que le défi de
toute la génération qui arrive c'est
d'éviter la réification des humains
c'est à dire qu'en gros qu'on ne soit
qu'une pareil
transformer en objet en chose que
le 1 et le 0 d'un algorithme global et
pour ça il y a deux choses qui sont qui
me semblent capitale pour garder cet
aspect humain un c'est la culture
générale parce qu'en fait même quand on
dit aux enfants aujourd'hui d'apprendre
à coder en fait demain le code sera
automatique donc en fait même là dessus
ils seront potentiellement entre
guillemets remplacés et donc seul la
culture générale permet d'avoir une
vision holistique et deuxièmement je le
réaffirme ici c'est le rôle des
politiques parce que quand on parlait
tout à l'heure de ce que disent ukerberg
et de la conception qu'il a de ce qu'il
est si à un moment les politiques ne
disent pas
peut jouer à armes égales avec des
personnes aujourd'hui qui sont mues par
des intérêts financiers assez rapidement
ce sera des intérêts financiers qui
primeront tout à fait alors Charlène
Biondi quel frontière entre
intimité et l'activité numérique
je pense pas que le numérique en dépit
de toutes ces intrusions dans l'intime
et dans le privé transforment
fondamentalement la nature humaine donc
j'ai pas de crainte que on perd de notre
libre arbitre par l'utilisation des
technologies même quand on est
allégoriquement manipulé en revanche je
pense que le sujet c'est de
effectivement
réussir à retrouver une attitude
proactive à cette technologie et à
développer cette réflexion
une réflexion neutre et non et non
scandalisée par rapport aux effets même
négatifs de la tech pour essayer de
comprendre comment ça nous transforme et
donc choisir cette transformation
numérique alors Daniel Cohen je voudrais
terminer par une dernière question
vous inspirez dans votre travail
d'économiste d'économistes qui sont à la
lisière de la psychologie je prends sa
stéglise Daniel kahnman etc qui a
notamment montré que dans les discours
il y a un discours intuitif celui qui
est immédiat et un discours analytique
est-ce que vous pensez que le
l'algorithme aujourd'hui la civilisation
algorithmique ça va ça vise à une
uniformisation et par conséquent c'est
la narration humaniste qui est en danger
moi je suis assez inquiet plus inquiet
que vous peut-être parce que je crois
que nous sommes les
héritiers d'un humanisme qui n'est au
11ème 30ème siècle qui se développe à la
Renaissance et qui doit beaucoup à la
culture
Gutenberg de l'écrit ou
on peut
accéder au savoir en lisant un livre
sans être obligé de passer par la
médiation d'un prêtre il y a un auteur
qui s'appelle Caselli que vous
connaissez certainement qui dit un livre
c'est un contrat entre un auteur et un
lecteur l'auteur donne le livre mais ne
se mêle pas de la manière dont le
lecteur va l'interpréter et le lecteur
son contrat c'est qu'il va lire les 300
pages pour comprendre ce que l'auteur a
voulu dire ça suppose du temps ça
suppose une distance critique ça suppose
d'avoir les deux trois heures pour lire
le livre et aller du début à la fin nous
sommes malheureusement dans une culture
où la capacité d'attention que propose
le numérique se réduit c'est la fameuse
civilisation du poisson rouge donc on
pense dont parle Bruno patineau le fait
que Tik Tok l'emporte sur Facebook si je
comprends bien c'est parce que sur
Facebook les vidéos étaient trop longues
et que sur Tik Tok elles sont très
courtes et donc pour reprendre ce que
vous disiez de Cadman Karman distingue
un système 1 un système 2 système 1
c'est celui on va dire de la réactivité
je me déplace je vois une pierre qui
tombe je suis capable de me déplacer le
système d'eux c'est celui de Gutenberg
c'est celui où on prend le temps d'avoir
une distance critique par rapport à
soi-même et faire le raisonnement je
crains malheureusement qui est un
changement basculement dans ces deux
systèmes et qu'on arrive vers un système
beaucoup plus impulsif émotionnel ou le
temps de la réflexion deviennent
impossible bref je crains pour dire des
grandes phrases qu'on sorte de la
civilisation humaniste celle de
Gutenberg ça a commencé en réalité avec
la télévision dans les années 60 on voit
cette distance s'opérée par rapport à la
capacité de réflexion de lecture et je
crois qu'on est en train d'en sortir
complètement les jeunes beaucoup plus de
mal à rester concentré sur un livre
moi-même quand je lis un livre
maintenant j'ai compris je mets tous mes
engins dans une autre pièce mon portable
et ma tablette etc parce que sinon je
sais que toutes les 5 minutes va être
tenté de regarder ce qui se passe et la
lecture devient presque plus pénible
alors que je suis un grand grand lecteur
plus pénible si je suis à fonction je
crois que c'était c'était Gérald Brunet
qui disait on a vu que quand le
téléphone sonne ça allume les mêmes
cellules nerveuses que quand on appelle
votre nom c'est-à-dire que vous êtes
dans un rapport
ombilical à cette chose qui vous
détourne du temps de la réflexion donc
oui je suis plus alors la nature humaine
après c'est peut-être
dans un état terminé on va terminer
là-dessus est-ce que vous gardez un
temps pour le livre
Margot classe moi j'adore lire j'ai fait
des études littéraires donc je lis et
aussi il faut aussi comprendre la
nouvelle génération peut-être là il y a
un choc dégénérations mais la nouvelle
génération elle s'informe sur TikTok ça
aussi des conséquences parfois négatives
mais c'est une autre façon de lire parce
qu'ils lise aussi sur Tik Tok ils
apprennent des choses ces nouvelles
façons de consommer de l'information
tout simplement ça date toujours
et j'ai une réplique qui me vient de de
mon grand-père du et son âme et qui
m'avait dit ça une fois lorsque j'avais
dit mais ton téléphone sonne et il est
en train de lire un bouquin il adorait
lire il m'a dit je ne suis pas un
domestique je ne réponds pas quand on me
sonne très bien alors je vous donner une
brève bibliographie alors Daniel Cohen
homo numérique US la civilisation qui
vient finalement c'est une mise en garde
devant
j'allais dire ces progrès foudroyants du
numérique c'est ça vous voulez mise en
garde en même temps j'essaye de faire le
lien entre la tente que ça fait naître
et qui reste présente vous parliez des
révoltes des femmes iraniennes etc il y
a ça cette force anti-système qui vient
des années 60 et toujours présente mais
je pense qu'elle est profondément
contaminée par cette révolution
néo-conservatrice qui fait qu'on est des
individus face à un système qui est plus
fort que nous si vous pouvez juste
ajouter une chose c'est pas juste
l'individu et la machine il faut
vraiment retrouver le sens des
institutions on va parler à propos des
réglementations pour ne pas être juste
seul face à ce choix on aboutit
réinstituer je ferai ce commentaire
c'est qu'à une époque où l'économie
politique se vide de son versant
politique je le sentiment qu'avec la
psychologie vous ramenez à cette
économie politique pour la
responsabilité c'est bien ça c'est vrai
que ce soit ça alors Charlène Biondi
vous avez publié décoder chez bouquin
bon on apprendra décoder ce qui se passe
c'est bien ça tout à fait on apprend à
décoder ce qui se passe et puis pour
revenir en fait on partage le même
constat je suis aussi d'accord enfin le
constat du livre c'est celui d'un
transformation d'ordre civilisationnel
mais qui mais qui n'est pas forcément
négative voilà alors je conseille à ceux
qui l'ont pas lu un ouvrage tout à fait
actuel qui s'appelle les liens
artificiels de Nathan Dewaere est écrit
comme un polar qui montre un peu les
déviations et la fascination pour le
numérique je voudrais signaler la
fabrique du crétin digital de Michel
desmurgers et qui est lié à ce qu'on a
dit sur les dangers des écrans pour nos
enfants et je voudrais signaler alors
Margaux Klein vous avez publié bonjour
richesse évidemment on a tendance à
penser à Bonjour tristesse mais c'est
vous
mais vous mais vous y avez pensé je le
lisais en fait quand j'ai écrit ce livre
je lisais je relisais Bonjour tristesse
j'ai juste voulu ouvrir et arrêter de
diaboliser le mot richesse très bien il
peut être multiple Jonas à date vous
avez un livre à nous proposer
une anecdote sur un bouquin que j'ai
écrit en 2014 que j'avais appelé droite
2.0 et que j'avais proposé un certain
nombre de politiques à l'époque je vous
cite ce qui m'avait dit avec mon coeur
Michael mais il dit tout ça c'est des
trucs de jeunes startupeur le numérique
n'aura aucun impact sur la société vous
voyez comment on peut faire des
prévisions fausses qui rejoignent ces
idées fausses dont parler Spinoza et qui
empêche la puissance d'agir merci
mesdames merci messieurs d'avoir
participé à cette émission je remercie
l'équipe de SCP et avant de nous quitter
je vous suggère cette pensée de Serge
Tisseron
l'instinct surexposé menace la
construction du mois
[Musique]